film and several are listed in your
program our third nominated film is the
Iron Lady please welcome Jay Roy Helen
Roy is credited with mrs. Streep's hair
and makeup this is the first Oscar
nomination for Roy and it s an aside Roy
am I correct that you have been missus
miss Streep's makeup artist for 37 years
that's 37 years of beautiful films and
beautiful looks Roy joins us from New
York where he completed working on great
hope springs and has been traveling
everywhere as you can imagine with Meryl
Streep with all of her nominations and
we have mark Collier mark Collier is
credited as the prosthetic makeup
designer mark is joining us from London
where he is shooting Rush and we'll be
starting season 5 of Merlin this is the
first Oscar nomination for mark The Iron
Lady was filmed in England and two weeks
ago won the BAFTA the British Academy of
Film and Television Award for makeup and
hairstyling
and Roy did you have something you would
like to say
well I really wanted to come because I
heard how you talked about the actors
when they're not here Wow Michael Gambon
ray Fiennes I got imong it on the phone
Meryl I understand this was the second
film that you've done that involves some
prosthetics yeah yeah yeah okay now
that's got to be one a very courageous
thing to do to you have to really have a
tremendous amount of confidence in the
people that are working with you because
otherwise as we've seen in other films
this year doesn't work out as well can
you tell us just a little bit about that
I know you've been with with Roy for
many many years and you found mark and
you tell us a little bit about that yeah
I I mean I hesitated when we about
whether we've worked with prosthetics
more than once because i remember i
played an old lady in out of africa and
we also did it in bridges of madison
county and we also did it in yes was
prosthetics talking it was prosthetics
in out of africa i forgot all about that
and takes a village between us we have a
memory half
and bridges of madison county was
stretch and stipple they don't consider
that process okay and angels in america
was also yes stuff put on wasn't it
wasn't molded oh I see but you played
Mamie old in evening and that was that
was Priscilla long prosthetics and they
had a lot of crap on my face for you
know the one where my head turned around
whatever that was death becomes her
thank you that's true we knew we had to
really think hard about the process of
covering for decades in someone's life
and someone who's very well known and so
we we interviewed a number of teams
makeup teams in in England and just
thought marks portfolio and his general
creative just what not lying yes The
Lying was particularly good in the
interview no we just thought you know
you have an instinct about people it's
just like it with actors you just know
it's gonna work out great and and we
were so grateful that we found you thank
you
I know that you know in comparison to
other films certainly in comparison to
to harry potter this was a much lower
budget film you worked so wonderfully
with with the appliances which a lot of
people have difficulty did you have an
opportunity to practice with that work
with that for a little bit know that we
did three full tests one of the aging
makers and 02 Indians we did too we
baited moment to start in January and
then we started in november and december
we did tests in London two different and
we just kept taking things away yeah but
I mean basically we we sculpted the neck
appliance and we took a mold of the
whole face and neck because we got the
neck pretty close on the first test
wasn't it would just really worked the
neck on the for a test and yeah then we
we sculpted we were then able to sculpt
different versions of this first clip
because I think we can see that
sculpting actually on them on the the
mold
so this was a sculpture actually done by
Barry Gower who was one of the crew
members in applied helped apply the
makeup with me the prosthetics with me
and Roy next clip please that was our
house our house and this is all we have
because we had 14 million dollars for
the movie and so these are rented wigs
Peter Owen made lovely wigs and they are
now probably on the crowd in in The
Hobbit movie but they are gone so this
is the only time anybody gets to see
them together and this was my little
workroom that I had in our mouths and I
would come home every night and clean
and reset and get up in the morning and
have a cup of tea and calm them out and
take them away and that's it and there's
actually one in the middle there that we
didn't get to use because we did a whole
series of still photography in one of
the test days and I had to cut one of
the wigs really short for this one
period in lady Thatcher's life and then
they cut that out of the script so I
lost a wig see the next clip please that
that's me taking the eyeglass mark out
because in between she would be reading
or doing or whatever and then I would
have to know don't tell everything
next please this is me using one of my
really tiny subtle large painting
brushes know what I'm doing there is
actually taking shine off using a bit of
anti-shine next please that's the that's
the kind of reaction you want to get wow
that's the first picture that was
released it was about our second or
third day of second day of filming Incas
and they wanted to release a picture and
they did and they didn't know that it
was going to be that's important as it
was next please
is that a great transition you want to
discuss this a little bit where did this
come in on the film this is when she's
leaving the doctor's office and is hit
by the paparazzi as she's coming out of
the Harley Street doctor's office no
Meryl you I you know I really want to
talk about this because this is really a
great example of really how much you did
and how little you did and i think that
the balance of those two things is what
is the secret of a successful
application and a successful ability to
perform through those things because
when i looked in the mirror I saw me and
that was really really important to me
you know i didn't want to see something
alien like another blob of head that
didn't belong to me i wanted to be able
to have my eyes express but with two
elements the nose piece which widens the
bridge of my nose which is very very
narrow and the neck those two things
create this this similarity to Margaret
Thatcher but leave me complete freedom
to live through the the the makeup I
didn't think about the makeup I saw my
face and that that really helped mostly
the other actors because no one that was
never a hesitation aura or people didn't
notice the makeup they they looked and
behaved as if I were an old woman so
much so that when I went out on the
street one day in 20 years I've never
been able to walk
London without anybody looking at me you
know I know I know this and I'm really
used to how to how to do it successfully
to hide but I could walk straight down
the thing and people would avoid me
because that's how we feel about the
elderly and she was dressed in a very
fancy Burberry raincoat in a Tony part
of town yeah santa bag lady I'm so
grateful that to these fellows and Barry
Gower who because it's just masterful
collaboration it really was we see the
next clip please yes see they can't
claim any of that forehead that's me now
that was something that I thought was
wonderful because in the bake-off Rick
Baker actually asked the question was
there an appliance in the forehead and
you said no there wasn't and I got to
thinking afterwards you created that
Meryl by raising your eyebrows mm-hmm
because in the end the shot before two
shots before your forehead was
completely smooth so in raising your
eyebrows you had to be very conscious of
that throughout along with everything
else that you were doing but it also
would seem to me that that would have
raised her eyebrows which in this case
what you're almost really wanting to do
is drop the eyebrow but it's interesting
how this works so well and is so
different than two shots before yeah
because we didn't even do any stipple we
did a lot of painting on the forehead
painting in all the all the age spots
and stuff and but ran the eyes we didn't
use any stipple work or anything any
stretch and stick no but Roy applied all
the little
things around the eyes that make it
old-age makeup you know the redness and
the and the shadow and the deepening of
the socket and all that stuff next clip
please but mark did add those there's a
very distinctive line of brow that
Margaret Thatcher has and Mark added
that those two sort of deep furrows
going up into my forehead he attached
that to the nose piece so that really
distinctive she had in the beginning we
wanted to I wanted to have a whole brow
because ah because if she would look she
has sort of a predator birds men to her
face it looked like a hawk or a bird of
prey and and that was an image that I
was in love with and we we did go
through the motions of trying to make
that work but that's right we've talked
about that we we made it and we had all
the eyebrow hairs punched in but we
never even tested it now because the
first day the the small appliance just
worked the small appliances all you
needed and we can see how well all these
different wigs worked you know some of
it so so identifiable to her in some of
the younger ages and it was just
captured wonderfully her hair her hair
too dark so documented there's you know
you just I would go every day to the
wardrobe and find out what she was
wearing and then they would show me the
picture of Margaret Thatcher in that and
crank the girl that way
but talk about how you took the hair all
out I'll wake him we had oh you're not
supposed to know yeah you mean dying all
of this no taking hair ripping hair out
of the wig well some of them may be due
to be the younger wigs they needed
younger the wigs they needed to be
thinner and then when those big we had
names for all of them and the biggest
one was called Gloriana and that I still
didn't have enough hair in it to make it
back home at big enough and then what I
found when we were doing the old lady
and we had to do the dinner party and i
was looking at pictures of Lady Thatcher
now and I thought but her hair is bigger
than when she was in office and the
Gloriana days and I realized that they
actually have made her hair now bigger
so that's in the exact same proportion
of her shoulders as it was when she was
in office so that it her body doesn't
look bigger she just looks in the same
proportion now at 85 as she did when she
was 65 but there's so much air in it you
can see right through it you know sort
of great next clip please oh this is
after work
this is team Maggie the full team Maggie
and then you can see very prominently
the edge of the appliance I love this
picture because to me it's toasting you
the audience also like this is a good
one where we haven't mentioned I think
there's a set of dentures there isn't
there yes mm-hmm the Margaret Thatcher
had a lot of problems with her teeth
over over the course of her lifetime and
in fact when she began her life or as a
young woman her teeth her front teeth
receded in they sort of and yet we have
a we have an iconic image of her with
sort of buck teeth with a separation and
so the decision was should we
or which would be confusing to the
audience from the time she was young and
we decided since the youngest Margaret
would be played by Alexandra wrote two
different actress people might think it
was a mistake know if her teeth changed
appreciably from the time she was young
until the time she was very old so we we
pretty much stayed with the same
appliance and the same look and that's
that's the piece you see which is what
those guys what's a guy's name chris
lyons yeah from findings effects who
made the teeth this is great this is the
older set isn't it we have two sets the
younger younger version yeah they were
just the color was different fellows and
figuration of configuration was
acceptance and we used that same
principle with with wigs too because
Margaret Thatcher had actually many
different hair colors through her career
and we realized that the way the film
was going to be edited together and cut
back and forth and crossed that they
should all be in sort of the same value
so we can half before photography
started I stripped the color out of all
the wigs and read I'd them all the
similar color because we couldn't make
any one alright let's take a look at
this film clip and see all this
wonderful work together thank you to the
Meryl Streep for coming here on what you
can imagine is an extremely busy time
with their nominations
and I think we're ready for the clip